[Applause]
I've given my whole life to everyone for
so
long it's just been really important to
me to keep this a secret let's wash our
hands this is the first time that
something is just
[Music]
mine I'm going to be a
mom literally no one knows why own
family does Mell ever since I've been
mik all I've done is say the most
terrible things
that's people found out it would be
Paparazzi all over
Cedar I got you a surprise this is your
grandson Phoenix you serious
yeah what is that is that a real yes we
had he's so beautiful so perfect my life
is finally complete
I'm so
obsessed that's hot have you talk to
your mom about the book it's just not an
easy subject writing this book was one
of the most difficult experiences of my
life writing about things that I've
never told
anyone no this was embarrassed and
scared the fact that you couldn't come
to us and we had to read about it online
in a book it's not right for us to just
read about it in the
media what's your best advice not taking
that job I don't want to leave him they
this small for such a small window it's
hard to say no cuz you're greedy you're
very greed no I just like to work hard
people who are trauma victims have a
very hard time happily bonding with
their
children
living isn't you just part of
me